[Music]
foreign
Marsh is a name that has probably come
up in the daily cancellation before he's
a 45 year old creep who's gained
prominence in the groomer community
Through Tick Tock videos promoting
transgenderism to kids now according to
the bio on his website his videos have
received over 1 billion views in total
uh he goes on to Pat his stats and his
bio by claiming to be quote the first
non-binary public figure to appear on
National Television of course non-binary
simply means that he's a dude who wears
eye shadow and and women's clothing and
if you believe that Jeffrey Marsh is the
first guy to do that on TV I would like
to introduce you to something called the
1980s
where it was quite common there's
nothing bold or pioneering about
cross-dressing in fact at this point
it's much more unique for a man to
appear on television wearing men's
clothing if you really want to be a
trendsetter simply dare to be normal in
this Society one other possible note of
interest from Marsha's bio
it says quote Jeffrey has studied and
taught Zen for over 20 years their
rigorous training while living as a monk
at a Buddhist Monastery in California as
chronicled in his book How To Be You
resulted in Jeffrey receiving the status
of precepted facilitator in the Soto Zen
tradition of Buddhism the rank of
precepted facilitator is an elite
category and marks a Zen practitioner
trained to assist anyone towards
spiritual growth
so in keeping with his distinctive and
individual individualistic approach to
life Jeffrey Marsh calls himself a
Buddhist
just like literally every other liberal
white guy in California and by the way
at the risk of butchering Buddhist
teachings
um I don't pretend to be an expert on
the subject because I don't pretend to
be Buddhist unlike
Jeffrey Marsh
but I'm pretty sure that one of the
fundamental ideas in Buddhism is that
you're supposed to detach yourself from
desire
but the LGBT cult totally defines Itself
by its desires it teaches that life is
best lived in pursuit of what you desire
no matter what your desires might to be
might be this represents if anything a
kind of anti-budist philosophy it seems
to me
it's like that's the opposite of what
Buddhism is but I'll leave it to the
Buddhist to make that case
um today my concern is is one of the
most recent videos posted by this
non-binary Buddhist Zen cross-dressing
groomer monk in this video as he has in
so many other videos Marsh attempts to
definitively debunk the anti-trans
propaganda disseminated by vile
transphobes Like Yours Truly for example
here it is
hi kids there's no such thing as a boy
or a girl and I can prove it so gather
around the family the parents everybody
answer my questions you either say boys
or girls who's usually taller
oh boys okay but you've met some short
boys right you met some tall girls so
usually boys are taller but not always
okay who likes the color pink
girls okay
um but you've met girls who don't like
pink and you met boys who do like pink
so usually girls like pink but not
always
everything you can think of that makes a
boy or makes a girl
is usually but not always
some of them are not even usually
where does that leave you
free you get to like what you like you
get to be who you are
maybe you're even like me and you're not
a boy or a girl
wow brilliant
I mean the great thing about this
argument is that I can use it to erase
literally anything from existence for
example most penguins are black and
white but some penguins are albino and
have all white feathers therefore
Penguins don't exist the average length
of a novel is 90 000 words but some
novels are well over two hundred
thousand or even 500 000 words therefore
books don't exist here's an interesting
one the average IQ of a human being is
between 85 and 115.
the average IQ of a fruit bat is 2.3
Jeffrey Marsha's IQ is also 2.3
therefore human beings don't exist or
fruit bats don't exist or Jeffrey Marsh
is a fruit bat or perhaps all these
things are true indeed we might as well
say that fruit bats don't exist and also
Jeffrey Marsh is a fruit bat considering
that Jeffrey Marsh is claiming that boys
and girls don't exist while also
claiming that a boy who identifies as a
girl should be accepted and affirmed as
one
he demands that we affirm someone's
self-identity as something that
according to him doesn't exist
this remains one of the many many
self-contradictions and gender ideology
it holds it holds a sacrosanct an
individual's identification with or in a
particular sex category while at the
same time insisting that the sex
categories are mythological
there are no girls
and also that person over there with a
penis is one
you must accept him as something that is
nothing or else you have erased him even
though we're the ones who just erased
the entire category that he is claiming
membership in
there is no way to make sense of this
hopeless tangle of contradictions you
can't understand it because it is not
meant to be understood
Marsh justifies his Erasure of boys and
girls by pointing out that some girls
are taller than some boys and some boys
like the color pink
this is the left the level of
intellectual rigor that we get from the
left on this topic you probably don't
need me to explain why this reasoning is
flawed but I will anyway
um we speak about height and color
preference in terms of averages
okay in particular height anyway we talk
about averages and especially
um the existence of outliers within a
category
does not throw the existence of the
entire category into question on the
contrary you need the outliers in order
to come up with the average you cannot
have an average without the outliers
that's the whole point of the average
but the fact that we can come up with
averages Within These categories and
then compare the categories against each
other is a pretty good indication that
the categories exist
if we can say anything at all about a
category okay if we can make any
statements if we can offer any
descriptions of any kind
then that means the category exists
the very statement not all boys are tall
automatically validates and confirms the
existence of boys as a category because
you're talking about them if they didn't
exist the statement would be meaningless
it doesn't make any sense to speak
descriptively about a group of people
who according to you are fictional it
would be like if you wanted to prove
that leprechauns don't exist and so you
said you know not all leprechauns have
red hair some are blonde
okay so you're saying they do exist then
I mean you're describing them
so what we've learned here is that even
if you can only speak about a category
in terms of rough averages
that doesn't mean the category is
illegitimate or non-existent
but in the case of boys and girls men
and women we can actually speak much
more definitively March client March
claims that there's nothing we can say
about men or women that
would apply to every member of that
group and that's what's known as begging
the question okay not to be confused
with raising a question even though the
phrases are often used interchangeably
he is begging the question about sex
differences by embedding his conclusion
into the premise of his argument begging
the question he proves quote unquote
that men and women don't exist by
pointing out that there are no
definitive facts about them
but that argument could only even begin
to work if we assume from the outset
that it's true that there are no
definitive facts about them but it's not
true
I can say about men for example
that all of them are male
and all males are of the nature to
produce sperm and impregnate females
meanwhile all women are female and all
females are of the nature to produce OVA
and bear offspring
even the females who do not bear
offspring are still of the nature to do
so it is natural for them to do so they
are the only ones who can do so disease
or old age or genetic defect May prevent
them from doing so but that doesn't
change their nature the same in the
reverse is true for males
I can say that all human beings are of
the nature to walk on two legs it's
natural for us to walk on two legs a man
who loses a car and a leg in a car
accident or who's born deformed
still shares this nature
all humans are of the nature to be
self-aware and sentient conscious
this is one of the defining features of
human beings It Is What Makes Us human
and that doesn't change just because
some human beings are in a coma injury
or sickness has deprived Some Humans of
this natural function that doesn't mean
that it's not a natural function
in fact the man in a coma only confirms
that human beings are conscious because
we wouldn't be able to identify and
label unconsciousness if we weren't
conscious ourselves the exception proves
the rule this is true of unconsciousness
in human beings just as it's true of
infertility in women
in a similar way
if it wasn't natural for human beings to
possess basic intelligence and reasoning
skills I would not be able to identify
Jeffrey Marsh as being especially stupid
but human beings are supposed to have
basic reasoning and intelligence which
is how I know the Jeffrey Marsh's
bottomless stupidity is unusual
and possibly an indication of some sort
of brain disease or trauma
which is something that he should really
probably look into talk to his doctor
about
but in the meantime what I can say is
that he is canceled and that'll do it
for us for this portion of the show as
we move over to the members block hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]